what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some really exciting
news about Venom three we have to talk
about Spider-Man of course but
particularly which Spider-Man that Venom
is going to go up against in venom 3 and
one of those things we'll be talking
about today is also when to expect Venom
3 to release in theaters it looks like
we could have a good idea of when its
release date could actually be
for me what the hell are you
we are them
[Applause]
on second thought please
now things can be quite confusing based
off of the post-credits scene that we
got for Venom 2 and then the
post-credits scene that we got for
Spider-Man no way home and honestly it
was kind of a big slap in the face to us
Marvel fans the post credit for Venom 2
put Tom Hardy's Venom in the MCU but
then the post-credits scene for
Spider-Man knowing home took him out but
left a piece of the Venom symbiote
behind telling us that the next
Spider-Man film in the MCU would be
about Venom but it would not be Tom
Hardy's Venom however there is still
good news about Venom 3. and that good
news is it's still going to be about
Spider-Man it's still going to be a
Venom vs Spider-Man movie Tom Hardy has
expressed this multiple times and since
now Venom and Eddie Brock and the Sony
Spider-Man universe know who Spider-Man
is and the last thing that they said in
the post-credits scene of Venom 2 was
that they need to track down the
Spider-Man we're all assuming that this
is indeed what is going to happen but in
the Sony Spider-Man and universe now but
the really cool news about that is is it
could be Andrew Garfield Spider-Man that
we could see going up against Tom
Hardy's Venom and the great news is is
the new report today is that we could be
finding out more about Venom 3 pretty
soon as we have a report from Daniel rpk
that Venom 3 will begin filming from
June to September in the UK this year
and that's only about five months away
and you know what happens when they
start filming we start to get leaks we
start to get set photos and we just
learn more about the movie in general so
I would say we're only about five months
away from finding out who this
Spider-Man is going to be now hopefully
or maybe not hopefully depending on your
views about this but I kind of hope Sony
keeps it a secret I hope we are actually
surprised about who the new Spider-Man
could be but at the same time I do hope
it's Andrew Garfield Spider-Man he is
the only Spider-Man that really hasn't
gone up against Venom and no Tom
Holland's Spider-Man has not gone up
against in them yet however based off of
what we know Tom Holland has signed
another deal with Marvel Studios to
appear in six more movies in the MCU
three of them are new Spider-Man films
two of them are new Avengers films and
one is kind of a mystery right now
however rumor has it that Tom Holland
Spider-Man is going to be getting the
Venom symbiote black suit in Avengers
Secret Wars just like he does for the
very first time ever in the comics so
Tom Holland Spider-Man will indeed have
a Venom storyline which leaves Andrew
Garfield as the only one that wouldn't
have had a Venom storyline so I'm really
hoping that it is him in venom 3. now
Tom Hardy has expressed multiple times
and has teased on Instagram multiple
times that Venom 3 Venom vs Spider-Man
is the ultimate goal that if it were the
Olympics Venom vs Spider-Man is the gold
medal which he wants to go for and would
be insane to not go for plus not to
mention on his Instagram he did already
tease Spider-Man by teasing the Venom 3
script with a red s written on it not to
mention Tom Hardy has teased several
times Spider-Man and Venom on his
personal Instagram before deleting the
post at something that Tom Hardy is
definitely known for giving us a little
tease and then deleting it from his
Instagram very quickly because he knows
that people are going to screenshot it
and it's going to end up online and it's
going to end up in one of my YouTube
videos among many others but Tom Hardy
knows this and it's kind of a cool thing
that he does I actually like it so
according to the support production and
filming is going to start for this movie
in June of this year which means
pre-production is going to start before
that and as far as when Venom 3 is going
to hit theaters when its release date is
going to be we can kind of narrow it
down based off of how Venom 1 and Venom
2 operated the direct.com has pointed
out that the last two Venom films
production is usually officially kicked
off around a year out from the film's
ventual or planned release so the first
Venom film began production in late
October of 2017 and the movie actually
made its theatrical debut on October 5th
of 2018 a year later then Venom Let
There Be Carnage began filming on
November 15th of 2019 and it originally
planned to be released on October 2nd of
2020 but of course since the pandemic
happened and everything got pushed
around it would eventually get pushed
back to release in October of 2021 a
year later so it had some reshoots and
of course covid-19 affected it but it
was originally planned on being released
in theaters about a year after it began
production so going back to the report
from Daniel rpk from his latest patreon
post where he stated that Venom 3 is set
to film from June to September it's
looking like we're going to be getting
Venom 3 in 2024 most likely in October
because the past Venom movies both of
them had October release dates in fact
Venom Let There Be Carnage even after
they had to postpone the release date a
year was still eventually released in
October so it does seem like Sony likes
these October release dates and they
have done well for them in the past
however of course there is always the
possibility that Sony could change this
and want Venom to be a summer film
however with October and Halloween being
in October and that entire season kind
of being spooky venom does fit into that
category very well so if I had to assume
I would say October of 2024 is most
likely when we'll get venom 3 which is
most likely going to be Venom vs
Spider-Man however it could come before
that it could come summer of 2024 so we
have our window now of when the release
date for Venom 3 is going to be now
sadly Tom Hardy has kind of expressed
that this is most likely going to be his
final than a movie this is it and he
wants to go out on top by having it be a
Spider-Man film and right now we do know
that Sony is setting up a live-action
spider verse for their entire universe
Madame Webb is going to introduce well
Matt Adam Webb who is a cosmic entity
essentially who can travel throughout
the Multiverse so we're most likely
going to be introduced to many different
variants of Spider-Man in this new
universe that we're about to see from
Sony so since they have some Spider-Man
who are actually kind of disposable
right now because there's going to be so
many different variants I'm wondering if
this final Venom film will show venom
killing Spider-Man I don't think it's
something that will most likely happen
fans don't want to see Spider-Man die
but I know a lot of fans are typically
against the whole oh we're going to go
against each other but then in the end
we're gonna find a common enemy and have
to work together type of film much like
Batman vs Superman you knew one of them
wasn't going to kill the other and you
knew eventually they would team up
together to fight an actual villain so
they could avoid that since venom does
hate Spider-Man so much and just have
venom kind of defeat Spider-Man now that
doesn't mean he has to die but what a
Twist that would be but still I wouldn't
like to see Spider-Man die so as far as
any big news that could possibly be
coming out for Venom 3 it it's going to
come out very soon but it looks like for
the most part we know right now that it
is going to be a Venom versus Spider-Man
movie the only question is right now who
is going to play the Spider-Man Sony has
a lot of plans for their spider-verse
there are many different possibilities
but fingers crossed that it's Andrew
Garfield but hey let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below would you like to see him go up
against Andrew Garfield or would you
like to see him go up against a
different Spider-Man possibly a new one
let us know Down Below in the comments
and if you want to keep up to date on
Venom 3 and all Spider-Man news be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
Bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos for live updates you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof